[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Mike Perry I'm working on a
special crazy first time animated
episode of broad city been doing the
titles for years now and it's been
really fun to be a part of the project
since the beginning
[Music]
that open animation it's not separate
from the show it is part of the broad
city world Mike Perry he also has kind
of become our visual brand you know the
relationship with the titles versus what
I'm doing now for the for episode 404 it
means very different the episode
involves live-action world transitioning
into cartoon world the fully animated
part is about eight minutes so we have
to take the viewer on a journey from
from like before they consume to when
they're getting their buzz on to where
they're they're tripping their face off
like just wandering glowing canyons we
had written him this whole list of like
background jokes about like ten pages of
it you have to watch it so many times to
get all the jokes
there's a guy scape worrying along the
street but it's pancakes
he's on a pad of butter you know skating
on a pancake
every season they put one of their PAS
in the background just jerking off on
the street so we've been requested to
put him into our animator world is it
weird my nipples are sort no that is
perfectly normal
mine are bleeding one of the things that
I personally like think about when I
think about mushrooms as a drug is just
how often it fills you with a level of
kind of warmth and positivity and also
you know feminine and like glowing and
so as really is this really a great
opportunity to like kind of just get
into that into this drawing and having
it just be like just saturated with like
a really beautiful moment animated you
really feel like you're with the girls
tripping with them rate increasing the
trip decreasing and then like doing this
stupid thing of adding weed too early
and feeling that the wee I mostly sketch
out everything on paper I mean I cannot
iterate how important the sketchbook
part of the process is for me oh here we
go this is one of the first drawings I
did the mother is flying with babies
hanging from their breasts
that's comic-book so a lot of this
stuff starts in the books and then like
finds its way into the appropriate part
of the world this is this is the
possible like a cutout for the for the
music scene Abbi and Ilana are basically
playing the city as though it's like an
orchestra and so this would just be kind
of like a cut cut shot to like this this
scene of like jamming out as the whole
city as a whole city jams out you could
tell how much fun he had making this and
it's so I cannot wait for people to see
it
I love it
[Music]